bonsoir
donc mon rapport avec les ordinateurs
n'a pas toujours été tendre
je n'ai pas toujours été le premier de
la classe
mais chacun a droit à une seconde chance
au départ les ordinateurs jeux les cas
c'est gelé démonter je savais pas
vraiment comment ça fonctionnait
vraiment et je voulais en savoir plus ce
n'est qu'à mon arrivée à l'université
que j'ai su que ce n'était pas
nécessaire d'ouvrir ou de démonter un
ordinateur pour faire parler
l'information ensuite à mon arrivée à
l'institut pasteur de guadeloupe donc ma
formation de base qui est l'informatique
est venu se mêler à la biologie pour
former la bioinformatique
qu'est ce que c'est l'abus informatique
c'est un peu complexe
c'est vrai on peut retenir que c'est un
moyen de lutter pour expliquer des
problèmes biologiques
grâce à l'outil informatique à
l'institut pasteur de guadeloupe j'ai pu
réaliser une thèse de doctorat
ge est encadrée par le docteur nalinnes
rasteau guy qui avec son équipe
travaille sur la tuberculose depuis plus
de vingt ans donc la tuberculose qu'est
ce que c'est la tuberculose est une
maladie infectieuse qui tue chaque année
environ 1,5 million de personnes
c'est une maladie qu'on appelle un peu
la maladie de la pauvreté
il existe une dizaine de formes de
tuberculose
en fait on va voir tout à l'heure qui
sont représentées sous forme de génotype
ce qui pose problème aujourd'hui c'est
l'émergence des bactéries qui sont
résistantes aux antituberculeux donc aux
antibiotiques
donc à l'institut pasteur comme je les
dis bon j'ai été très bien accueilli et
finalement j'ai contribué à mettre au
point
développer et enrichir la base de
données mondiale la plus grande base de
données mondiale de germes tuberculeux
mais je n'étais pas seul ce travail est
le fruit de collaborations intense et je
tiens d'ailleurs à remercier tous les
collaborateurs tous ceux qui m'ont aidé
à réaliser ce projet je suis
reconnaissant envers tous ceux qui m'ont
accompagné et qui conte qui continue à
le faire
comme quoi dans une petite île des
caraïbes
on peut faire de grandes choses en
collaborant avec les autres donc
maintenant parlons de la base de données
la base de données elle contient
aujourd'hui plus de 120000 souche ou
génotype de tuberculose qui sont obtenus
à partir des patients donc des malades
donc si ces souches
on va voir tout à l'heure qu'on peut les
représenter sous forme de codes barres à
mon avis il est vraiment je trouve que
c'est nécessaire de faire tout ce qu'on
peut tout notre possible pour lutter
contre les maladies tout notre possible
pour préserver la vie et je pense que
tout un chacun tout le monde peut y
participer
la base de données donc grâce à des
techniques de laboratoire on extrait la
molécule adn des patients tuberculeux et
en se focalisant sur une région bien
précise
on arrive grâce à une autre technique
appelée génotypage on arrive à
identifier ces souches
donc là on peut voir que un génotype
représenté comme un code-barres le
premier code barre comme on peut le voir
c'est le code barre qui correspond à la
famille beijing c'est une forme de
tuberculose qui est souvent répandue en
asie de l'est
donc ces données sont rentrés dans la
base de données et on peut dire comme
des cartographies cartographie mondiale
donc un outil vraiment de surveillance
la base de données est un outil de
surveillance qui nous permet qui nous
aide à mieux contrôler la tuberculose au
niveau mondial et si on a un exemple de
distribution dans la caraïbes et en asie
de l'est
on peut voir que dans la caraïbe
on voit qu'il ya une ligne et une
famille de tuberculose en verre qui
correspond à la famille latine
américaine à une méditerranéenne et on
voit en asie de l'est
la famille beijing qui est prédominante
cette famille beijing est souvent
associé à des cas de tuberculose
résistante aux antibiotiques
la base de données et donc comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure un outil de
surveillance comme m bairi disais tout à
l'heure
ceci a un peu à prévenir aussi prévenir
les risques prévenir le danger dans une
danse est dans une sorte c'est à dire
que on a un problème aujourd'hui avec
l'émergence donc des antibiotiques
résistant et on a une pénurie de bons
traitements de meilleurs traitements n'a
besoin de meilleurs traitements pour la
tuberculose
donc cette base de données nous permet
de réaliser des études scientifiques qui
sont qui apporte en fait qui éclairent
notre compréhension de la maladie
de plus en plus cette base de données
permet également d'apporter de donner
aux des indices aux personnes
spécialisées donc aux services de santé
pour mieux lutter contre cette maladie
nancy quoi une base de données en
général on est entouré par des bases de
données les bases de données font partie
de notre quotidien que ce sera un
fichier excel de deux lignes ou un
carnet d adresses contient deux adresses
c'est déjà début de base de données on
va tous des phrases sur wikipédia on a
tous des smartphones maintenant j'espère
que oui oui oui non donc toutes ces
outils toutes ces applications ont
quelquefois on les voit pas mais il ya
ceux qui se cachent derrière ces des
bases de données les bases de données
sont un peu comme des gros cartons des
grosses boîtes de carton qui contiennent
des objets qui sont organisés c'est à
dire que chaque objet est à sa place
dans une base de données
chaque objet a un nom et voilà tout est
bien délimité les bases de données à mon
avis draft est toujours mise à jour est
entretenu mais c'est bien beau les bases
de données vous allez me dire mais
comment
voilà comment on les utilise qu'est ce
qui se cache derrière les bases de
données pour utiliser ces données pour
faire parler l'information on a besoin
d'autre chose on a besoin d'algorithmes
vont donc c'est quoi un algorithme un
algorithme en fait c'est une suite
d'instructions une suite d'instructions
qu'on va donner à la machine pour qu'il
réalise là un certain nombre de
traitements et cet algorithme là peut
être comparée de manière voilà en gros à
une recette de cuisine c'est à dire que
on a des données nous donner sont un peu
comme nos ingrédients de notre set et
l'algorithme c'est la façon de mélanger
tous ces ingrédients là pour obtenir
pour obtenir un plat délicieux
par exemple ce bobo quitte là que vous
voyez donc de la même façon que certains
styles musicaux permettent de 30 de
transformer l'énergie négative en
énergie positive
le data mining ou l'analyse de données
permet de récupérer des données mal à
ranger non classés en des données
pertinentes en informations pertinentes
donc l'algorithme c'est une forme de
ciment une forme de tuyauterie si on
veut dire qui permet de canaliser
l'information et de la faire parler
donc voila voila pourquoi les bases de
données me passionne m'inspire que ce
soit celles sur lesquelles j'ai
travaillé ou les autres elles font
partie de mon quotidien
ce qui m'inspire davantage ce sont les
histoires qu'on peut raconter grâce à
ces données
ces histoires sont un peu comme des
pièces d'une gigantesque puzzle qu'on
essaie de rassembler petit à petit on
n'est pas arrivé un an et c'est donc
toutes ces histoires ainsi que mon
expérience personnelle - amené à tirer
des principes clés dès que j'essaie de
suivre au maximum je veux aimer ce que
je fais mais aussi et messieurs avec qui
je le fais je veux chercher sans cesse
et avec espoir en me focalisant sur des
choses essentielles
la paix l'amour la simplicité je vais
prendre exemple sur des personnes
inspirante
je veux comprendre le monde dans lequel
nous sommes dans lequel nous vivons
ainsi que les organismes qui nous entre
les organismes du vivant je veux aussi
être à l'écouté de l'autre
je veux m'améliorer toujours mais c'est
bien aussi d'aimer ce que l'on fait
c'est bien mais il faut savoir aussi des
phrases déconnecté voilà on est on est
dans un monde connecté
quelquefois c'est bien de se déconnecter
prendre du repos se ressourcer avec sa
famille ses proches
merci